special counsels indictment in the
election meddling probe shows how easily
Russians allegedly manipulated social
media platforms the document mentions
Facebook 35 times and 37 pages Twitter
is brought up nine times and YouTube
once the indictment accuses the Russian
internet research agency of stealing
Americans identities creating fake
social media accounts and the illegally
buying advertising the Russian
organization employed hundreds of people
and had an annual budget of millions of
dollars the Russian propaganda included
ads like this one by the so called
army of Jesus linking Hillary Clinton to
the devil the Special Counsel says
Russians also organized events like this
anti Clinton rally called down with
Hillary Facebook estimates a hundred and
twenty six million Americans may have
seen Russia linked posts CBS News
contributor Nicholas Thompson is editor
in chief of Wired good morning morning
so how much to blame is Facebook for
having disseminated a lot of this
propaganda complicated question clearly
Russia used Facebook extensively should
Facebook have caught that still under
intensive debate you can argue from the
details in the Moller indictment to that
they should have caught it you can also
argue that it was very well disguised so
Facebook does deserve some blame what's
also interesting from the fact that
Facebook is mentioned so much in the
Muller indictment I think that's
probably a sign that Facebook cooperated
quite a bit so you could actually read
that in a good way for Facebook's
fascinating is that if you dive into
this indictment what they did with
Facebook they were organizing rallies
they made up these groups and people
showed up to the rally they're
organizing rallies and they're targeting
purple states right there's a fake
account created in the name of a fake
American who's emailing Tea Party
supporters saying hey we want to
organize in purple states let's get a
rally going please send us your network
purple states meeting battleground
battle you know that we know that
Hillary Clinton lost essentially the
electoral vote by about 80,000 votes in
key battleground states so it was a very
close election the question is did this
make any difference in that right we
should note that facebook says to your
point about cooperating that they are
continuing to work closely with the FBI
the Department of Homeland Security and
other companies on better ways to
protect our country and the people on
our platform can I ask you this question
ken Facebook's say this which is hey
have some culpability here but Americans
who think that Hillary Clinton is
associated with the devil or the Donald
Trump is associated with the devil need
to think through what they're reading
and engaged a little more actively in
democracy it's not all the social medias
platform can they say that or are they
just too much on the defensive well I
just wrote a story about Facebook and
which one of the people is quoted as
saying the problem is not Facebook its
people right and there is truth to that
right we should not have been
susceptible to all of this garbage
absolutely of course the emotional
things that the Russians played on
Facebook hopes to use those emotions to
keep people locked in I mean right so
this the the most sophisticated katika
Facebook is that they have made an
incredibly sophisticated platform for
targeting us in the most emotional ways
possible because that's what makes
advertising work that is also what makes
political propaganda work that suggests
that people who are not smart were open
to this type of propaganda there was a
Twitter account called ten underscore
GOP which reported to be Tennessee
Republicans do everyone from Kellyanne
Conway to Donald Trump jr.
to Michael Flynn all retweeted these
fake Twitter accounts that were made by
these Russian trolls
I mean what's interesting is that they
were very sophisticated the operation
and they're gonna get more sophisticated
and Facebook's gonna have to work really
hard to stop it the next time around as
well Twitter and the other companies can
they stop it
I hope so thank you